there are many descriptions of the
BIGBANG out there that are wrong
anything that says the universe exploded
from an infinitely small dense and hot
point known as the Big Bang singularity
her out of date but I've seen this
description in many places in diagrams
and on the Internet have even been
guilty of saying this too but I've
recently updated my understanding so
here's what cosmologists actually mean
when they say Big Bang we start about
13.8 billion years ago when space was
much smaller than it is today for the
sake of illustration I've drawn the
early universe as this little ball but
there's some caveats to this picture
which I'll clear up later in this tiny
universe space is very tightly curved so
if you traveled in a straight line you
wouldn't have to go far until you got
back to where you started the universe
doesn't contain any stuff yet no matter
or radiation it's just pure space and
this space has energy the universe
expands exponentially in a process
called inflation this means that it
keeps doubling in size so it would take
you longer and longer to do your
round-trip journey which means that the
curvature of space is getting lower and
lower until space got so big it was
essentially flat and you'd be walking
forever and then there was an end to
inflation the energy inherent to space
was turned into stuff matter antimatter
particles and radiation this is known as
the hot Big Bang and this is where all
the matter in the universe came from
even though inflation stopped space was
still expanding so over time this matter
became less dense and less hot first
there were just fundamental particles
then after a microsecond the quarks
condensed creating protons and neutrons
then a second later neutrino stopped
interacting strongly with the other
particles and flew free then after a few
minutes matter and antimatter
annihilated each other
mysteriously leaving behind some
leftover matter then protons and
neutrons came together to form the first
atomic nuclei of helium then after about
three hundred and seventy-nine thousand
years we reached the end of the hot Big
Bang when hydrogen and helium nuclei
captured electrons forming the first
stable atoms and photons stopped
interacting strongly with the other
particles and flew free as well we can
see these primordial photons today as
the Cosmic Microwave
background after that the universe
behaves in a more familiar way to us
slight and even is's in the distribution
of matter means that gravity pulls
matter into clumps which after about a
hundred million years get dense and hot
enough to start nuclear fusion and the
first stars shine then 600 million years
later the first galaxies form out of
collections of stars after inflation the
expansion of space slows down and keeps
slowing for many billions of years but
today we see that the expansion is
accelerating again we call whatever's
causing this accelerating expansion dark
energy we also see that matter is very
clumped together in galaxies and galaxy
clusters and that's the story of the
creation of our universe so why is this
our model of the beginning of the
universe
it's because this is the best
description we have that matches the
things we observe in the universe today
like the distribution of stars galaxies
and the temperature of the Cosmic
Microwave Background the Cosmic
Microwave Background is a key piece of
evidence about the early universe
because it says that everything in the
visible universe everything in the
massive radius of 46.5 billion light
years must have been in thermal
equilibrium at some point in the past
this means that it must have all been
packed into a tiny space and had time to
all be at the same temperature before
everything moved away from each other by
the expanding space the best scenario we
have to explain this is cosmic inflation
the old Big Bang singularity model
predicts other things like large
temperature fluctuations which we just
don't see so this idea that the universe
exploded out of an infinitesimal point
was thrown out 40 years ago now my
description of inflation was a little
over simplistic I did that on purpose to
get the main ideas across but I need to
clear up a few points when I said that
the universe started off being really
small that only applies to the patch
that became the visible universe today
but this visible universe is only one
section of a much larger universe and we
don't know how big that larger universe
was or is also I drew the early universe
as being a tightly curved ball but we
don't know if this is true either all we
know is that if there was any curvature
to space before inflation in
would have made it flat but space could
have been flat before inflation we just
don't know and we're not even a hundred
percent confident in this inflation
hypothesis it's simply the best idea we
have so far that fits the observations
and unfortunately there are hard limits
to what we can ever observe and no you
probably know that the further away in
space you look the further back in time
you're looking so that means the
earliest light we can see is from
recombination in the form of the Cosmic
Microwave Background so we can't see
further back beyond 379 thousand years
after the hot Big Bang by using light
potentially we can detect primordial
gravitational waves from before this
time but this will need a huge space
interferometer and even with the most
idealized experiments we can conjure up
in our minds we could only ever probe
the last fraction of a second of
inflation 10 to the minus 33 seconds
we can never see further back than that
because the information simply doesn't
exist in our universe but the takeaway
point is when cosmologists say Big Bang
they're usually talking about the hot
Big Bang which is a period of time after
the end of inflation stretching for
about three hundred and seventy-nine
thousand years so you might be wondering
what happened before inflation what
actually started the universe although
lots of people are thinking very hard
about this it's still a big mystery we
don't know how long inflation lasted we
don't know what existed before inflation
we don't know how big the whole universe
is and we don't know if time started or
if time has existed forever and perhaps
we'll never know the answers to these
questions but of a feeling that's not
gonna stop us from trying to work it out
but let's give a big shout-out to Katie
Mack for helping me understand some of
these concepts she's really good at
explaining cosmology and astrophysics as
you go to follow her on Twitter also I'm
doing a run of these Big Bang posters
check them out on my store on dftba
thanks again for watching see you next
time
[Music]